[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday some day
in November and it is snowing all over
the place fantastic
look it's my house it's covered in snow
soon I will be covered in snow it never
snows this much in Missoula it's
fantastic I need gloves I'm gonna have
to go get gloves that's not the power
one off like five times because the big
tree branches are falling everywhere
onto power lines as well as onto our
front yard and I got gloves I can do
this okay apparently holding onto a
video camera while you throw a snowball
makes you throw like a that is not
how I throw snowballs if you see me
throwing a snowball at you that is
because I want you to see me throwing a
snowball at you so Katherine and I took
this snowy opportunity to go on a walk
and it was nice and I videotaped a few
things I'm gonna share those with you
Katherine was sad because this little
bush was laboring under the weight of
all that ice and snow and so she went
under it and she shook it and it was
awesome and this guy obviously just
moved here from somewhere else because
he's in his driveway in his shorts
cleaning his car with a hockey stick who
doesn't have a car cleaner thing we have
a car cleaner thing in fact we have two
she's gonna be mad at me for showing all
of you that so I'm just gonna remind her
what she did to me earlier today okay
she has very good aim she missed the
camera she hit me in the head right oh
sorry
only marginally only marginally Kevin
and I are taking this beautiful
opportunity to walk down to the farther
away food store which is bigger and
better than ours it's nice out then
we're gonna do our Thanksgiving shopping
behind me you can see the mountains of
Missoula
that's actually a hanger of some kind
there there I thought the town kind of
freaked out a little bit thousands of
people without power and so on we have
arrived thousands lose power isn't that
what I just said coming inside of the
store it's a warm in here and then I
apparently got to be occupied solve that
warmness and all of the food and I
stopped videotaping stuff so that's okay
really because you don't wanna watch me
grocery shop that's not exciting and
this is this is exciting why do you
watch me sorry John that wasn't for you
that was for the nerdfighters why this
is weird
who's in there that's not what I want to
talk about though I want to talk about
my bizarre fondness for cold weather
where the hell back come from we grew up
in Florida you and me grew up in Florida
we got bundle up first like sixty
degrees it hit 30 degrees one time while
we lived in Florida once dad dragged us
out of the house like 6:00 in the
morning so we could see frost on the
roof oh my god frost and then when I
moved here my head you know exploded
initially I've never seen an icicle in
person I've never seen a snowflake
before I've never seen a river freeze
over all of these things were very new
and very interesting very cool but what
I've realized in the years since not
only do I like the cool new stuff that
comes along with coldness I also really
kind of like being cold I like my house
to be around 60 degrees that's a good
temperature I work better I'm more
comfortable I like winter it's kind of a
shock to me it was I was surprised to
realize that recently and I'm glad
winters back because I've been dreaming
of a white Thanksgiving and I sure got
one
speaking of which finally a holiday
falls on one of my days so you just need
to do a video tomorrow and then I do one
on Friday and nobody does one on
Thursday because it's Thanksgiving and
on Friday I will tell you some of the
things that I am thankful for but today
let's just be thankful that you and
David told your book
that is so awesome congratulations John
I'll see you tomorrow
25 622